präsident wir kommen bei phoenix zu dem
sender in dem sie vermutlich am
häufigsten zu sehen sind allerdings
nicht im studio sondern an ihrem
arbeitsplatz und das ist der deutsche
bundestag der plenarsaal
wir freuen uns sehr dass sie zu uns
gekommen sind in unser studio den
fernseh gesprächssendungen gehören
normalerweise nicht zu den orten zu den
dingen den sie sich mit besonderer
zuneigung zu finden
es kommt sehr auf das format an herzlich
willkommen seit elf jahren sind die
bundestagspräsident solange angela
merkel auch kanzlerin ist
sie haben jetzt ihren rückzug aus der
politik verkündet vor kurzem wenn wir
jetzt mal diese elf jahre sollen wir
nicht revue passieren lassen und vor
allen dingen auf das schauen was sie so
besonders geprägt haben nämlich das
deutsche parlament
was würden sie sagen in welchem zustand
befindet sich unsere parlamentarische
kultur zurzeit das ist wie vieles im
leben sehr von der perspektive abhängig
wenn ich von außen den deutschen
parlamentarismus mit vergleichbaren
verhältnissen in anderen ländern in
europäischen und nichteuropäischen
ländern
vergleiche komme ich zu einem
außerordentlich freundlichen geradezu
schmeichelhaften befund wenn ich von
innen unsere arbeitsabläufe unser
erscheinungsbild unserer reputation
betrachtet ist das bild deutlich
eingetrübt und beide perspektiven haben
natürlich ihre berechtigung also mit
anderen worten der deutschen
parlamentarismus ist ganz sicher besser
als sein ruf
aber er ist auch nicht ganz so gut wie
er sein könnte und wie sich manche ihn
sympathischer weise offenkundig
vorstellen wenn wir uns die der das
derzeitige politik und und
verfassungsverständnis der deutschen
einmal anschauen würden sie sagen dass
wir da auf eine krise zu steuern würden
sie sagen wir haben eine krise der
repräsentativen demokratie weil er ein
andere sich dann eben doch nicht mehr
richtig repräsentiert fühlt also so
lange wie es den parlamentarismus gibt
wird seine krise behauptet man kann das
übrigens für die deutsche
parlamentarismus geschichte besonders
schön zeigen und leider lässt sich auch
nicht bestreiten
das ist nicht nur eingebildete sondern
tatsächliche krisen gab und die erste
deutsche demokratie ist auch und gerade
was ihre parlamentarischen strukturen an
ging nach weniger als 14 jahren zu ende
gewesen
im vergleich zu dem was ist tatsächlich
mal an krise deutscher demokratie und
des deutschen parlamentarismus gegeben
hat haben wir heute mit ich will nicht
sagen komfortablen problemen zu tun aber
jedenfalls nicht mit unüberwindlichen es
gibt eine reihe von kritischen einwänden
und ganz sicher trifft zu dass sich
manche mit ihren sorgen einwänden
kritischen positionen im parlament nicht
oder jedenfalls nicht hinreichend
erkennbar vertreten fühlen
das ist ein schwer bestreitbar befund
den übrigen auch darin zum ausdruck
kommt dass sich dieses bedürfnis neue
adressen sucht das ist aber ohne den
vorgang deswegen für belanglos zu
erklären was ich ausdrücklich nicht tue
zugleich ein nachweis für die vitalität
dieses systems das ist ganz offenkundig
solche veränderungen nicht nur
ermöglicht sondern begünstigt der
deutschen parlamentarismus hat sich wenn
wir jetzt über den nachkriegs
parlamentarismus reden
in fast 70 jahren immer wieder verändert
immer wieder gehäutet ich will nicht
sagen immer wieder neu erfunden aber
doch erkennbar weiterentwickelt wir
haben mal mit einem zwölf parteien
parlament angefangen das kann sich heute
fast keiner mehr vorstellen
kommunales ich hab also wieder dann
haben wir zwischenzeitlich fast zwei
jahrzehnte einen drei parteien oder drei
fraktionen parlament gehabt was viele zu
der wiederum vor einigen
schlussfolgerung veranlasst hat das sei
die verfassungslage
das im deutschen bundestag drei
politische gruppierungen vertreten sind
dann kamen die grünen die manche für ein
vorübergehendes phänomen gehalten haben
und die sich in der zwischenzeit fest
als weitere politische gruppierung
etabliert haben
dann gab es die piraten von denen manche
angenommen haben das sei die nächste
dauerhafte veränderung hat sich
herausgestellt er eine vorübergehende
erscheinung als eine dauerhafte
erweiterung des politischen spektrums
insofern ist jedenfalls die
veränderungsfähigkeit und erneuerungs
fähigkeit dieses systems deutlich besser
als gelegentlich vermutet wird
machen sie gerade gesagt es fühlen sich
nicht alle gleichermaßen in dieser
repräsentativen demokratie auch mit
ihren meinungen und vorstellungen im
parlament abgebildet inwieweit hat denn
die große koalition auch dazu
beigetragen dass dieser befund auch
nochmal duo an gewicht gewonnen hat ganz
sicher tragen große koalitionen dazu bei
dass es durch die bündelung von
politischen auffassungen zweier größerer
politischer gruppierungen und die
notwendigerweise dann zahlenmäßig
deutlich kleinere minderheit in einem
parlament auch zu einer anderen
öffentlichen präsentation von
politischer urteilsbildung kommt als das
bei anderen politischen konstellationen
der fall wäre
nun muss man aber auch da finde ich der
fairness halber sagen dass wir jetzt im
deutschen bundestag zum dritten mal aber
auch erst zum dritten mal in 18
legislaturperioden eine große koalition
haben war erkennbar nicht der dringende
wunsch des einen oder des anderen
partners sondern beide partner haben
diese koalition eigentlich nicht gewollt
sie kam am ende zu stande weil
rechnerisch andere denkbare
konstellation politisch nicht zu
realisieren waren
und insofern muss man solche abwägungen
immer auch unter dem gesichtspunkt nicht
nur theoretisch sondern
praktisch verfügbare alternativen wollte
das mal beiseite genommen aber schwächen
grundsätzlich große koalition auch den
parlamentarismus und damit die
repräsentative demokratie man das wenn
ich damit ein bisschen übertrieben sie
sie verkürzen die wahrnehmung ein
bisschen weil es eben einen unterschied
macht ob einer mehrheit von sagen wir
mal 55 oder 58 prozent der mandate im
deutschen bundestag eine beinahe gleich
große opposition gegenüber steht oder ob
wir jetzt 80 prozent der mandate von den
beiden größeren parteien wahrgenommen
werden mit all den folgen die das auch
für verteilung von redezeiten und damit
von wahrnehmbarkeit von positionen nach
sich zieht
dass große koalitionen prinzipiell
tätlich wären für parlamentarische
strukturen oder abläufe finde ich lässt
sich nicht ernsthaft aufrechterhalten in
deutschland übrigens noch weniger als
anderswo weil wir inzwischen eine
politische kultur entwickelt haben wie
beispielsweise zu beginn dieser
legislaturperiode dazu geführt hat dass
wir über die vorgaben der verfassung und
der geschäftsordnung hinaus den beiden
oppositionsfraktionen besondere
minderheitsrechte eingeräumt haben
in dem bewusstsein dass die
größenordnung ist jedenfalls fair
erscheinen lassen ihnen
gestaltungsmöglichkeiten einzuräumen auf
die sie keinen rechtsanspruch hätten das
heißt da haben sie ja maßgeblich zu
beigetragen dass die rechte der sehr
kleinen opposition im aktuellen
bundestag gestärkt und das hat geholfen
jedenfalls hätte ich sie alleine nicht
veranlassen können es ist völlig richtig
das ist nach meinem amtsverständnis auch
eine der
vornehmsten aufgaben eines
parlamentspräsidenten sich nicht darum
zu kümmern dass die mehrheit sich
durchsetzt das ist ohnehin
sichergestellt sondern dass die
minderheit zu wort kommt und dass sie
ihre rechte wahrnehmen kann
aber ich hätte das bei aller
begeisterung für dieses amtsverständnis
ja nicht durchsetzen können wenn es
nicht bei den koalitionspartnern
einsicht in diese notwendigkeit gegeben
hätte und da werden schon ein bisschen
kämpfen darum also die einzelinterviews
bekämpfen müssen wäre es offenkundig ja
auch kein wirklich schwieriges und
ernsthaftes anliegen gewesen aber sie
müssen in europa weit laufen um ein
zweites parlament zu finden das in einer
vergleichbaren situation zu
vergleichbaren regelungen bereit und in
der lage wäre
wie wichtig ist denn diese regelung wenn
man sich auch mal anschaut das ja in den
letzten jahren durchaus so eine art
politikverdrossenheit auch auch war die
wahlbeteiligung stetig gesunken ist
jetzt aber so eine art umkehrtrend kommt
das ist doch eigentlich eine gute
entwicklung für demokratie und für
persönlich habe mich ja auch an der
panik debatte über vermeintliche
unaufhaltsam rückläufige wahlbeteiligung
nie beteiligt habe das immer für eine
überschätzung eines themas gehalten das
durchaus eine bedeutung hat wir müssen
wir glaube ich keine zwei minuten
darüber reden dass hohe wahlbeteiligung
erfreulicher sind als niedrige
wahlbeteiligung aber weder habe ich das
was es an rückläufigen wahlbeteiligungen
in jüngerer vergangenheit gegeben hat
für einen unaufhaltsamen trend gegeben
noch für ein menetekel weil wir selbst
in unter berücksichtigung dieser etwas
zurück gegangenen wahlbeteiligungen im
internationalen vergleich nach wie vor
in der spitzengruppe rangiert haben wir
haben uns über viele jahrzehnte daran
gewöhnt dass wir außergewöhnlich hohe
wahlbeteiligung insbesondere bei
bundestagswahlen immer hatten
und weil landtagswahlen jedenfalls auch
in einer sehr vorzeigbaren größenordnung
das was wir jetzt erleben ist so ein
bisschen auch mit oder ohne
anführungszeichen eine normalisierung
von
hemmnissen vergleichbar zu anderen
gestandenen viel länger funktionierenden
demokratien
das hat vielleicht ein bisschen auch
damit zu tun dass das bedürfnis dass es
vielleicht nach dem zweiten weltkrieg in
der damaligen generation ganz ausgeprägt
gab nämlich den nachweis zu führen dass
uns das sicher kein zweites mal passiert
eine demokratie scheitern zu lassen dass
dieses aus eigenen biografischen
erfahrungen entstandene bedürfnis in
nachfolgenden generationen aus
verständlichen gründen nicht mehr
vorhanden jedenfalls nicht mehr so
ausgeprägt ist und sich insofern
deutsche in ihrem wahlverhalten in
ähnlicher weise verhalten wie franzosen
und italiener und briten und amerikaner
auch wobei die amerikaner stolz wären
wenn sie bei ihren höchsten
wahlbeteiligung in die nähe der
niedrigsten deutschen wahlbeteiligungen
überhaupt kennen so und im übrigen haben
es angedeutet bei allen landtagswahlen
in diesem jahr 2016 hatten wir einen
deutlichen anstieg der wahlbeteiligung
was ja auch wieder ein indiz dafür ist
dass je nach politischer lage und dem
eindruck der wählerinnen und wähler ob
es einen unterschied macht vom eigenen
wahlrecht gebrauch zu machen auch
wahlbeteiligung steigen oder
und viele dieser ehemalige nichtwähler
so nenne ich es mal zieht es ja nun zu
bewegungen oder zu parteien die piraten
hatten sie schon angesprochen die afd
ist ja eine neue partei auf diesem
spielfeld wie kommt das erklärt sich das
also ganz grundsätzlich hängt mit genau
den punkt zusammen mit dem wir das
gespräch begonnen haben
wenn sich auffassungen besorgnisse
kritische positionen die es in der
bevölkerung gibt
im parlament nicht oder jedenfalls nicht
deutlich erkennbar bemerkbar machen
dann suchen sich in einer
funktionierenden lebendigen demokratie
diese interessen und bedürfnisse einen
neuen adressaten und das war der
grundsätzliche hintergrund für die
erfolgsgeschichte der grünen
die zwei themen erfolgreich besetzt
haben
die für eine beachtliche
etliche minderheit der damaligen
gesellschaft an bedeutung gewonnen
hatten und die sie in den etablierten
politischen parteien nicht mit den
notwendigen stellenwert versehen sein
und das gilt heute in einer ähnlichen
weise wider wobei wir ganz konkret mit
blick auf die jüngere entwicklung einen
etwas ungewollten aber schwer
vermeidbaren preis für eine der
errungenschaften der parlamentarischen
kultur in deutschland zahlen für die es
wiederum nur wenig beispiele anderswo in
europa gibt wenn wir mal von den vielen
themen die in dieser legislatur fördern
eine rolle gespielt haben zwei
herausgreifen die besonders kontrovers
in der öffentlichkeit diskutiert worden
sind das migrations thema mit der damit
verbundenen flüchtlings thematik und das
thema griechenland hilfen zu denen es
jeweils sagen wir mal erkennbar
deutliche zurückhaltung in beachtlichen
teilen der gesellschaft gegenüber der
politik gibt die von dieser koalition
von dieser regierung und den sie
tragenden fraktionen betrieben wird
dann würde man normalerweise erwarten
dass diese kritik diese einwände diese
besorgnisse von der opposition
mit pauken und trompeten lautstark und
mit sämtlichen verfügbaren
blasinstrumenten bedient werden was
findet bei uns statt
warum setzt sich die opposition hin
denkt über die komplizierten
zusammenhänge nach und sagt am ende
kommen wir zu dem ergebnis vereinfacht
das jetzt mal dass das was die regierung
macht wohl doch vernünftiger ist als die
alternativen die dagegen ins feld
geführt werden der migrationspolitik
stimmt das bestimmt in der finanzpolitik
euro eher nicht da hat die opposition
gerade die linken ja doch naja aber die
grünen haben regelmäßig mehrheitlich
stimmt das mehrheitlich den hilfspaketen
zugestimmt da war aber dann genau einer
der punkte wo es auf meiner aus meiner
sicht
völlig unverzichtbar war auch und gerade
aus dem grund den wir gerade diskutieren
dass die minderheiten die es in allen
fraktionen gab die gegen diese linie
eintragen
auch im parlament zu wort kam das ist ja
eine der größeren auseinandersetzung
gewesen den gesang und klein haben
untereinander hatten und mal vom
parlaments verständnis ganz abgesehen
darf man sich nicht wundern wenn sich
bürgerinnen und bürger die mit ihren
besorgnissen und anliegen und kritischen
einwänden nicht hinreichend vertreten
fühlen umso entschlossener neue adressen
suchen wenn diejenigen die im parlament
diese auffassung vertreten entweder gar
nicht oder nur selten zu wort kommt
nicht dass dann auch daran dass diese
themen die sie gerade angesprochen haben
auch in ihrer komplexität und in den
nachwirkungen und und erweiterungen die
es hat vielleicht auch für den einzelnen
zu kompliziert sind und diese anderen
bewegung eben einfachere antworten
bieten ist dass das forum der wiener
dort vielleicht ob gut oder machen sich
damit zu einfach indem man das so
erklärt einfache antworten sind immer
scheinbar schlüssiger eingängiger
jedenfalls leichter zu vermitteln als
komplizierte und leider trifft für fast
alle wichtigen fragen mit denen wir
gegenwärtig zu tun haben für fast alle
wichtigen innenpolitischen wie für
europa und außenpolitische fragen zu
dass die einfachen lösungen die am
wenigsten richtigen sind so dass man um
die komplizierten eben nicht herumkommt
die zu vermitteln nun allerdings eine
der klassischen aufgaben der politik ist
ich glaube dass sich sobald man
überhaupt verschiedene phasen einer
politischen entwicklung unter einem
solchen gesichtspunkt voneinander
sortieren kann die gegenwart nicht
dadurch von früheren legislaturperioden
unterscheidet das heute alles ganz
schnell
ich wäre während es früher alles ganz
einfach gewesen wäre das glaube ich
überhaupt nicht aber ich glaube dass
tatsächlich der komplexitätsgrad enorm
zugenommen hat und das ist damals
tatsächlich für klarere zu entscheidende
sachverhalte auch klarer nebeneinander
zu stellen der alternativen gab also
jetzt so ein beispiel
ob wir überhaupt nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg jemals wieder deutsche
soldaten haben dürften oder gar müssten
ob man zu diesem zweck eine bundeswehr
wieder errichtet und ob es wehrpflicht
gibt das sind jeweils fragen zu denen
man jeweils plausibel ja oder nein sagen
können wenn wir heute über europa
politik diskutieren werden sie nur ganz
ganz wenige finden die ernsthaft die
auffassung vertreten
nein wir machen nicht europa sondern
jeder sagt natürlich sind wir europäer
natürlich wollen wir europäische
lösungen so und dann geht's ans
eingemachte
was soll überhaupt und wenn ja wo und in
welcher zuständigkeit mit welcher art
von mitwirkungsrechten zu und schon sind
wir in genau den komplizieren
gelegentlich auch dass das erhöht die
strahlkraft der politik nicht aber man
muss der versuchung für komplizierte
fragen einfache antworten anzubieten
tapfer wieder stellen und muss sich dann
dieser mühsame aufgabe unterziehen zu
erklären warum so einfach eben nicht ist
sich so richtig verstanden habe ist das
ja auch wähler will der sich artikuliert
auf der straße in demonstration in
protesthaltung auch gegen das was im
routinierten politikbetrieb upload ist
das nicht sind ja ein großer freund der
auch kämpferischen debatte ist das nicht
ein beitrag zu einer vitalen
debattenkultur was wir da teilweise
erleben auch wenn uns das nicht immer
gefällt in der stoßrichtung
na ja also ich würde jedenfalls die
vitalität einer debatte nicht an der
lautstärke messen und ich würde mich
auch immer weigern unflätige
temperamentsausbrüche für besondere
vitalität nachweise zu halten
ich habe um das noch mal zu sagen viel
verständnis für diejenigen die sagen uns
gefällt die europäische haushaltspolitik
nicht wir haben einwände zum euro oder
der handhabung der wechselseitigen
vertraglichen verpflichtungen die mit
dessen einführung verbunden waren und
oder wir haben probleme mit der
flüchtlingspolitik
aber ich bin nicht bereit diese einwände
die nicht nur zulässig sondern auch in
vielen fällen sehr ernst zu nehmen sind
deswegen für eine general erklärung für
beliebige formen der einlassung der
beschimpfung der verleumdung auch der
tätlichen angriffe entweder auf
handelnde politiker oder auf
berichterstattenden journalisten oder
auf betreuende meist ehrenamtliche
mitbürger in entsprechenden
einrichtungen durchgehen zu lassen
das heißt appell an die zivilität im
umgang aber kommen wir noch mal auf
diese neue gruppierung zurück auf die a
f d die trägt er im namen schon
alternative und versteht sich ja auch
als eine alternative gegen eine so
empfundene all parteien regierung sie
habe eben selbst gedacht dass auch in
der opposition bei der behandlung von
strittigen sachfragen man am ende sich
dann doch einig was dann häufig
wahrgenommen wird als
ich benutze man dieses filmte wort
kartell gegen das man sich dann
politisch zur wehr setzt indem man so
eine gruppierung dann ins leben ruft wie
gehen sie damit um dass das was im
parlament und was bei den sogenannten
etablierten parteien passiert dass das
von vielen menschen auch als
meinungsdiktatur geradezu wahrgenommen
wird für die es eine alternative bedarf
na gut also der begriff meinungsdiktatur
wäre wieder freundlich formuliert
erkennbar übertrieben denn es gibt nicht
nur nach unserer verfassungslage sondern
auch in unserer politischen realität
kein monopolanspruch für niemanden
nicht mal für die spitzen von
verfassungsorganen gibt es einen
exklusiv anspruch geschweige denn
monopolanspruch zur vertretung ihrer
jeweiligen positionen oder überzeugungen
und jede auffassung die bei uns
vertreten wird muss sich prinzipiell der
kritik und denkbaren alternativen
stellen
mit blick auf die gruppierung die sie
angesprochen haben zeigen ja auch alle
bislang dazu vorgelegten studien und
wählerbefragungen dass der großteil der
attraktivität für diese wählerinnen und
wähler in genau diesem anspruch besteht
eine alternative zu sein und nicht in
den konkreten vorschlägen die sie zu dem
einen oder dem anderen thema haben also
wenn ich jetzt die zahlen richtig in
erinnerung habe haben auch in den
wählerbefragungen nach den vier
landtagswahlen dieses jahres etwa zwei
drittel der afg wähler erklärt sie
würden die partei nicht wählen oder
hätten sie nicht gewählt um deren
politik zu unterstützen sondern um
deutlich zu machen dass sie probleme mit
der politik haben die ihnen von den
etablierten parteien oder dem was ich
jetzt gerade als kartell verdächtigt
haben angeboten
kommen so das heißt hier sucht sich eine
position ein ventil und das finde ich
zunächst mal gut nachvollziehbar da wo
jetzt diese partei als neue gruppierung
in parlamente eingezogen ist wird sie
den nachweis führen müssen ob sie diesen
anspruch auch einlösen kann nicht nur
alternative sein zu wollen sondern
alternativen zu haben
dieses ventil von dem sie gerade
sprachen
warum braucht es das ist das eine
persönliche angst die bei den wählern
umgeht oder wie würden sie es
interpretieren was ist das
also ich möchte auch gerne dass meine
interessen vertreten werden die wetten
dass vermutlich auch lieber als den
umgekehrten eindruck dass alle möglichen
interessen vertreten werden nur ihre
nicht das finde ich also einen ganz
normalen reflex der im übrigen nicht nur
politische wirkungen und ansprüche
auslöst aber auch und gerade für die
politik von besonderer bedeutung ist und
dass es sich im übrigen bei den themen
die er erkennbar
die palette von der besorgnis bis zur
offenen wut bedienen
weder um erfundene probleme handelt
sondern um tatsächlich und das ist dazu
auch nicht nur zulässig sondern nötig
ist
über andere lösungen nachzudenken als
diejenigen die mehrheiten gefunden haben
daran muss man sich selbst gelegentlich
erinnern und gelegentlich auch
miteinander reden und muss dann am ende
aber immer wieder darauf hinweisen dass
schon gar bei den wichtigen problemen
wir die option nicht haben
solange nichts zu entscheiden bis alle
einer meinung sind sondern diese
probleme müssen in welcher weise auch
immer gelöst werden
und auch wenn man sich für komplizierte
themen so ist denn überhaupt geht die
nötige zeit nehmen muss sie lassen sich
nicht beliebig vertagen
und wenn es dann nach einer gründlichen
debatte untereinander und in der
öffentlichkeit erkennbar nach wie vor
sehr unterschiedliche positionen gibt
dann muss mit mehrheit entschieden
werden und mehr als entscheidungen sind
gewissermaßen das kleine einmaleins eine
funktionierende demokratie
wobei man auch da wiederum gelegentlich
mehrheiten daran erinnern muss dass die
mehrheit nicht der nachweis der
richtigkeit der eigenen meinung ist
sondern das verfahren auf das man sich
gerade deswegen verständigt hat weil
niemand nachweisen konnte dass seine
position die richtige ist und deswegen
alle am ehesten akzeptieren dass das
gilt was eine mehrheit entscheidet
solange wenig eine neue mehrheit was
anderes entscheidend ist ja in
wirklichkeit noch einmal kurz kurz
nachfragen denn das was sie beschreiben
ist ja die mehrheit war ja für die
bisherigen politischen oder für die
etablierten parteien immer die mitte
sozusagen und alle streben dorthin in
die mitte ist das ein fehler
letztendlich in die mitte und wird es in
der mitte zu eng ich meine wenn man dann
in andere länder guckt dann kann man
auch sagen die ränder sind dann auch so
stark dass man die frage stellen muss
was ist mit dieser mitte ist das der
richtige weg dorthin zu streben und
finden sich da wirklich auch noch mehr
halten auch mittelfristig und
langfristig die frage kann ich ihnen
jedenfalls nicht allgemeinverbindlich
beantworten ich kann aber sagen dass wir
hier schon in verschiedenen benachbarten
europäischen ländern ganz
unterschiedliche politische kulturen
haben
ihrer beobachtung würde hier vermutlich
kaum jemand widersprechen dass die
auseinandersetzung bei uns immer
mindestens rhetorisch aber ich glaube
auch über die rhetorik hinaus in der
sache
der kampf um die mitte ist in frankreich
käme keiner auf die idee die politische
auseinandersetzung als einen kampf um
die mitte zu interpretieren sondern es
hat immer klare teilweise
knallhart konfrontationen zwischen einer
rechten und einer linken gegeben und
wahlen sind von daher immer als
richtungsentscheidungen verstanden
worden sowohl von den konkurrierenden
parteien selbst als auch von den
jeweiligen wählerschaften ich wäre auch
sehr zögerlich dass eine für die
offenkundig richtige um das andere für
die offenkundig überholte
versuchsanordnung zu halten das hängt
mit der geschichte mit dem
selbstverständnis von ländern zusammen
ich finde es allerdings auch wiederum
nicht so sonderlich erstaunlich dass wir
nach unseren erfahrungen mit dem
scheitern einer deutschen demokratie und
der entsetzlichsten verehrung die es
danach jemals gegeben hat uns in einer
anderen weise um eine imaginäre mitte
herum gruppieren wollen als das in
anderen ländern üblich und möglich ist
und fällt einem jahr bei der behandlung
das vermutlich dominierenden thema aus
der deutschen politik im vergangenen
jahr der flüchtlingsfrage es schwer
irgendwie da noch von mitte zu reden das
scheint sicher an dieser frage sehr viel
zu polarisieren ist die flüchtlingsfrage
eine frage in der sich auch viel
unbehagen an ganz generell art bündelt
und ist das vielleicht auch damit
erklärbar dass sich darin eben viele
wiederfinden die ohnehin sorgen haben
über die künftige entwicklung die von
abstiegsängsten auch bedrängt werden ja
erfahrungsgemäß gibt es immer solche
mitnahme effekte und dass der eine oder
andere vielleicht auch ein diffuses
allgemeines unbehagen gegen alles und
jedes dann bei einem thema einparkt dass
sich zur mobilisierung von protest und
vielleicht auch von widerstand besser
eignet als diese oder jene er zweiter
oder dritter einige frage das kann ich
mir schon ganz gut vorstellen dennoch
würde ich uns empfehlen
das was ist daran auch organisierten
einwänden gibt nicht in der weise zu
banalisieren und zu sagen das ist halt
politikverdrossenheit die leute wohin
mit all ihren nicht leicht hinweggehen
kann also wenn es tatsächlich ein indiz
wäre für politik politikverdrossenheit
dann wäre das ja anlass für die politik
da auch zu handeln also vielleicht auch
dinge stärker zu erklären
um eben sich der bevölkerung
verständlich zu machen und sie auch
mitzunehmen auf dem weg wird
ich finde ich kann ja ohnehin mit dem
begriff politikverdrossenheit nicht viel
anfangen weil ich ihnen für den gut
gemeinten aber misslungen und versuch
halte eine bestimmte entwicklung die wir
in deutschland haben auf einen begriff
zu bringen
ich kann nicht erkennen dass es heute
eine eine prinzipielle verdrossenheit an
politik oder eine prinzipielle distanz
gegenüber der politik gäbe aber ich
erkenne natürlich schon das ist eine
erkennbare verdrossenheit über konkrete
entscheidungen über konkrete verfahren
über konkrete personen über konkrete
konstellationen gibt die sich im übrigen
in vielen fällen sehr politisch äußert
also dafür finde ich den begriff
politikverdrossenheit er quer und das
bei uns auch und gerade in der zeit über
die wir jetzt reden in allen
einschlägigen umfragen immer um die 90
prozent der befragten sagen sie finden
das politische system das in unserer
verfassung im grundgesetz definiert ist
vernünftig und richtig und jedenfalls
allen denkbaren alternativen überlegen
und gleichzeitig 50 bis 60 prozent je
nach umfragen sagen aber mit dem
konkreten zustand dieses landes seien
sie nicht zufrieden
das kann man doch auch für den nachweis
von urteilsvermögen halten wenn ein und
die gleichen leute in der lage sind zu
sagen mir gefällt vieles nicht aber ich
weiß dass das system in dem wir das
abarbeiten
besser ist als irgendeines was dafür
sonst auf dem markt ist und umgekehrt
wenn diejenigen die von der
überlegenheit einer parlamentarischen
demokratie über 2
sind deswegen vor begeisterung nicht
gleich so besoffen werden dass sie nicht
mehr in der lage sind fehlentwicklungen
zu sehen die es in einem solchen system
doch geben kann
und offenkundig gelegentlich auch gibt
finde ich spricht eher für
urteilsvermögen die unzufriedenheit die
sich da im moment bahn bricht
manifestiert sich vor allen dingen bei
den punkt migrationsbewegungen wie wir
ja vorhin schon kurz angesprochen hatten
wenn man sich das anschaut ist es ja vor
allen dingen sind es viele die einfach
sagen wir wollen nicht mehr dass
flüchtlinge kommen wir wollen
obergrenzen wir wollen hier eigentlich
auch die mauer bauen und noch einen zaun
aufbauen und ähnliches das ist aber ja
eigentlich eine debatte die wir so nicht
führen sollten sondern vielmehr sollten
wir darüber nachdenken über unsere bunte
gesellschaft und wie wir die integration
tatsächlich auch führen können es ist
das was in der flüchtlings debatte
zurzeit stattfindet ist das das richtige
wie sie diskutiert wird oder läuft es in
eine völlig falsche richtung
jedenfalls wird die diskussion nicht
leichter wenn wir sie so wie ich sie in
ihrer frage jedenfalls verstanden habe
mit dem ausschluss einer position
beginnen und sagen ob wir überhaupt
flüchtling akzeptieren wollen oder nicht
darüber dürfe doch und können noch gar
nicht geredet werden doch auch darüber
darf geredet werden denn natürlich ist
die frage legitim ob wir das eigentlich
wollen
und wenn wir es wollen in welchem umfang
und unter welchen bedingungen wird das
können
ich habe keinen zweifel daran heute
genauso wenig wie vor einem jahr
dass die ganz überwiegende mehrheit der
wählerinnen und wähler und der
bevölkerung in deutschland von einer
abschottung eine abgrenzung nichts hält
die einen aus prinzipiellen gründen die
anderen aus praktischen gründen viele
aus sowohl prinzipien die praktischen
gründen
aber ich musste auch diejenigen ernst
nehmen die sagen doch im prinzip dagegen
mit denen muss man dann die frage ob das
prinzipiell
durch eine kluge position ist ruhig ohne
schaum vor dem mund aber gründlich ja
sie fühlen sich ganz offenkundig nicht
ernst genommen jedenfalls nicht
hinreichend ernst genommen und da sind
wir dann auch wieder bei formen der
debattenkultur die dieses ernst nehmen
auch in vielen fällen ich sag mal
zurückhaltend nicht erleichtern
aber wir dürfen uns auch vor einwänden
nicht wegducken bei denen wir uns
subjektiv sicher sind dass darüber doch
eigentlich gar nicht geredet werden
müsse wenn offenkundig ist dass es
menschen gibt die an der stelle
ernsthaft ein problem haben gibt es nur
die beiden möglichkeiten dass man sich
damit ernsthaft auseinandersetzt
oder man signalisiert denn bei uns kommt
er jedenfalls nicht vor
dann dürfen uns aber nicht darüber
beklagen dass die dafür dass sie
vollkommen neue lösungen suchen treffer
war das stichwort von dem beklagen auf
sie haben am dritten oktober eine sehr
bemerkenswerte rede gehalten in dresden
zum tag der deutschen einheit
das wurde so empfunden als eine art
ruck-rede sie haben für optimismus
plädiert darüber gesprochen dass
deutschland eigentlich ein besserer
standort ist als er in der einschätzung
der deutschen bevölkerung manchmal
wahrgenommen wird fehlt es uns
gelegentlich an diesem optimismus an
dieser zukunfts gewandtheit und auch an
einer gewissen gelassenheit im umgang
auch mit phänomenen die und in den
letzten monaten eher bedrückt haben also
jedenfalls gibt es eine bemerkenswerte
diskrepanz zwischen dem zustand in dem
sich unser land befindet schon gar im
vergleich zu anderen ländern in europa
und weit darüber hinaus und der
ausgeprägten begabung zur selbstheilung
über das was uns entweder noch nicht
oder noch nicht in der gewünschten weise
perfekt gelungen ist
nicht hat schon vor vielen jahren eine
ein aufsatz sehr beeindruckt in die
damals noch nicht so bekannte inzwischen
hoch dekorierte schriftstellerin juli
zeh einmal geschrieben hat ich glaube
mit dem titel anleitungen zum
selbstbewusstsein oder so ähnlich wo sie
schildert dass sie dann wenn sie selber
zweifel am eigenen land hat sich ins
ausland begibt und da regelmäßig zu
einer neuen sortierung der verhältnisse
komme und sie sagt jetzt vielleicht auch
nicht ganz wörtlich aber hoffentlich nah
dran
das sei immer schon eine herausragende
begabung der deutschen gewesen alles
ziemlich richtig zu machen und alles
entsetzlich grauenvoll zu finden
jedenfalls ist die außenwahrnehmung
deutschlands in einer geradezu
berührenden weise erstaunlichen weise
positiv geprägt und unsere setzt
einschätzung von bemerkenswerten
selbstzweifeln gekennzeichnet ich habe
dazu ja auch in dresden ein paar
beispiele vorgetragen mit diesem
virtuellen glücksatlas wo die deutschen
sich selber zwischen senegal und kenia
einsortieren
während eine wissenschaftliche studie
die für das weltwirtschaftsforum in
davos vorgelegt worden ist und ich
glaube 20.000 meinungsführern in weiß
der teufel wie vielen ländern der welt
zu dem ergebnis kommt unter würdigung
aller objektiv zu berücksichtigen
indikatoren sei deutschland wohl das am
besten organisierte land der welt nun
müssen wir nicht solche superlative vor
uns her tragen und dass wir damit eher
zurückhaltend umgehen finde ich grund
sind paten recht vermutlich das finde
ich wirklich grundsympathisch aber wir
sollten uns auch nicht für schwächer und
schon gar für schlechte halten als wir
sind gerade vor wenigen tagen hat die
britische regierung eine studie
vorgelegt wo die zukunftschancen der
jungen generation in 183 ländern der
welt untersucht worden sind das stelle
ich mir als hindurch ambitiöses vorhaben
vor da sind
nämlich alle länder die es überhaupt auf
diesem globus gibt ich glaube die
vereinten nationen haben gegenwärtig 198
mitgliedstaaten und nach ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie vielen kriterien sind dann die
zukunftschancen der jungen generation
sortiert worden welches land schneidet
am besten ab
deutschland so also noch mal die
wichtigste beschäftigung schon gar für
handelnde politiker sollte nicht das
wechselseitige schulter schlagen sein
daher wichtigeres zu tun aber wir
sollten uns weder einreden lassen noch
selber den eindruck vermitteln als
lebten wir leider auf einem besonders
schwierigen teil der welt die wahrheit
ist dass all diejenigen die irgendwo in
der welt anlass zu der frage haben ob
sie da wo sie leben
eine wirkliche zukunftsperspektive haben
das vermeintliche paradies auf erden
nirgendwo häufiger vermuten als in
deutschland hilft denn da auch gegen
populismus und andere irgendwie eher
unschöne erscheinungen mit denen wir im
augenblick konfrontiert werden auch
schon schuss mehr optimismus und sind
wir dazu neu gestimmt und wäre das beste
gegengift tatsächlich irgendwie so sich
dessen auch bewusst zu werden was sie
gerade angesprochen haben und was auch
in ihrer rede in dresden an rolle
gespielt
also ich sage gelegentlich optimismus
und pessimismus sind keine politischen
kategorien dafür kann man sich nichts
kaufen
in der regel sind die optimisten etwas
fröhlicher im umgang mit gleichen oder
ähnlichen herausforderungen wie die
pessimisten das heißt die einen wie die
anderen können sich das herangehen an
aufgaben vor denen sie sich nicht
drücken können oder sollten
mental erleichtern oder erschweren aber
die problemlösung muss immer in der
sache gefunden werden
ich würde deswegen nicht für optimismus
werben wollen
aber für ein gesundes selbstbewusstsein
für ein selbstvertrauen das auch dem aus
dem nachweis dessen was uns gelungen ist
begründet werden kann
sprechen sie ja die verantwortung der
medien auch an damit weil
die sozusagen für die zumindest die
veröffentlichte meinung aber eben in
großen teilen auch die öffentliche
meinung welche rolle spielen die dabei
lesen sie dann und sehen sie dann zu
viel akzentuierungen im negativbereich
und zu wenig selbstbewusstsein und zu
wenig positive beschreibung der
wirklichkeit dass man im einzelnen mit
berichterstattungen und oder
kommentierungen von sachverhalten nicht
wunschlos glücklich ist kann ich gerne
bestätigen aber auch mit blick auf die
medienlandschaft in deutschland könnte
und müsste ich einen ähnlichen befund
vortragen wie ich zu beginn unseres
gesprächs zur bestandsaufnahme des
deutschen parlamentarismus vorgetragen
habe wenn ich von innen sozusagen in
dieses system gucke fällt mir vieles ein
und auf was mich nicht so richtig
begeistert und immer wenn ich aus dem
ausland zurückkommen will ich ganz
begeistert über das deutsche medien
system über das verhältnis von print zu
elektronischen medien von öffentlich
rechtlichen zu privaten anbietern und
auch da sind beide perspektiven
mindestens berechtigt zu den auffälligen
veränderung aber das muss ich ihnen
nicht erläutern gehört das will ich das
richtig sehe zum ersten mal in einer
nachhaltigen weise die presse in einen
ähnlichen generalverdacht geraten ist
wie die politik auch das hat es
jedenfalls in meiner wahrnehmung in den
ersten 50 jahren der deutschen
nachkriegsgeschichte nicht gegeben und
zwingt sie eigentlich zu ähnlichen
überlegungen wie wir sie vorhin mit
blick auf parteien und parlamente und
verfassungs institutionen diskutiert
haben
es ist interessant was sie sagen dass es
sozusagen politik und medien da auf
einmal in einem boot sitzen
heißt das im umkehrschluss dass es so
eine art im ideale parallelwelt gibt die
sich nämlich dann vor allen dingen im
netz wiederfindet wo wir in den sozialen
medien durchaus ausbrüche und und auch
eine eine sprache finden die man mit
verboten bezeichnen könnte und die man
so auch benennen muss um hinten
anzufangen ja das muss man nicht nur zur
kenntnis nehmen sondern ernst nehmen und
ich glaube auch dass wir uns da was
einfallen lassen sowohl die medien wie
die politik politik jetzt verstanden als
gesetzgeber auch verstanden als justiz
hier sind formen der folge fast
inbegriff kommunikation zu nennen aber
ich bin jetzt mal in anführungszeichen
hier ist eine kommunikationskultur
unterwegs die den mindest ansprüchen an
ernsthaftigkeit und zumutbarkeit im
umgang miteinander nicht genügt und die
wie ich glaube auch nicht tolerabel ist
die wichtigste einzelne ursache dieser
entwicklung ist technischer natur
nämlich die möglichkeit der
verfügbarkeit über das internet in einer
bis dahin völlig unbekannten auch nicht
vorstellbar kurzen zeit eine
unvorstellbar große zahl von leuten
unter welcher art von titeln begriffen
ankündigungen auch immer zu tatsächlich
oder scheinbar bedeutsamen politischen
gruppierungen zu erklären da werden auch
viele scheinriesen erzeugt die aber
schatten werfen im wörtlichen und
übertragenen sinne schatten werfen die
vielleicht sogar eine spaltung unserer
gesellschaft hervorrufen könnte und wird
sich auch das als mediale parallelwelt
tatsächlich bezeichnet wollen da bin ich
jetzt nicht hinreichend
sachverständig ich befasse mich intensiv
mit dem was da gewissermaßen ankommt und
uns erreicht und registriere mit einer
gewissen fassungslosigkeit auch zu
welchen verbalen entgleisungen sich die
menschen zunehmend auch mit klarnamen
hinreißen lassen
und wenn sie jetzt nach der parallelwelt
fragen habe ich fast die vermutung dass
diese parallelwelt nicht eine
parallelwelt in der gesellschaft ist
zwischen solchen die damit nichts zu tun
haben und einer kleineren zahl die sich
darin verbarrikadiert sondern dass das
teilweise parallel existenzen von
bürgerlichen personen sind die wenn sie
was ja jetzt gelegentlich stattfindet
von angegriffenen angesprochen worden
ganz erschrocken sind dass irgendjemand
diese verbale explosion nicht nur
registriert sondern ernst genommen hat
ein ganz merkwürdige befund mit dem wir
uns aber glaube ich gründlich befassen
müssen
nun haben wir über die form des umgangs
gesprochen
die gibt es von seiten der bürgerinnen
und bürger gegenüber der politik auch
gegenüber den medien
umgekehrt kann man sagen manchmal
schlägt dann die politik auf zurück es
gibt das beispiel eines bekannten
bundesministers der im zusammenhang mit
den demonstrationen von peder von pac
gesprochen hat ist das eine angemessene
reaktion und oder ist das einfach nur
eine menschlich verständliche reaktion
also eine menschlich verständliche ist
es glaube ich allemal eine kluge ist es
schon sehr viel weniger weil außer
denjenigen für die das vielleicht sogar
zu trifft sich immer eine größere zahl
von menschen angesprochen fühlt für die
es sicher nicht so trifft und die sich
dann ausgegrenzt und ihrerseits
beschimpft und mit ihren anliegen oder
besorgnis nicht ernst
das ist nun tatsächlich eine der
ungemütlicheren anforderungen für
mandatsträger aber im übrigen sicher
auch für journalisten dass sie sich
selber die entgleisung natürlich
verbieten müssen denen sie selber
ausgesetzt sind sie haben einmal gesagt
deutschland ist in europa beinahe das
einzige land in dem sich die politische
mitte nicht aufzulösen droht würden sie
diesen satz uneingeschränkt heute
wiederholen denn wir haben ja zumindest
das phänomen dass die volksparteien wenn
man überhaupt noch von volksparteien im
plural sprechen kann dass die einem
enormen druck ausgesetzt sind dass sie
auch unter auszehrung leiden und da auch
schon ein gewisser erosionsprozess im
gange liste sicher die flügel er stärkt
als die mitte also dass wir eine sehr
viel stärkere differenzierung von
interessen haben oder da umgekehrt dass
sich heute immer individuellere immer
spezifischeren immer ausgeprägtere
interessen viel weniger gut bündeln
lassen als das in der vergangenheit der
fall war ist ein offensichtlicher
befunden und eine der nahe liegenden
erklärungen auch für die stärkere
differenzierung früher starker und
inzwischen deutlich schwächerer
volksparteien
dennoch glaube ich ist er ist die
beschreibung nach wie vor im kern
zutreffend wenn auch von ihrem eigenen
anspruch her konkurrieren die relevanten
politischen gruppierungen nicht um
ränder sondern um die mitte wobei es
zugegebenermaßen aber ich glaube auch
aus dem genannten grund ihnen schwerer
gelingt wählerinnen und wähler menschen
zu integrieren
die früher unter sortierungen
gewissermaßen ihrer wichtigen und
weniger wichtigen interessen sich dann
am ende
der einen oder der anderen gruppierung
eben doch verbinden konnten sich durch
sie hinreichend vertreten sein was heute
nicht mehr in gleicher weise geschieht
aber dass sich die auseinandersetzung
von einem kampf um die mitte in einen
kampf um die ränder verschoben hätte das
ist jedenfalls meine wahrnehmung nicht
wenn sie sagen dass es ihre wahrnehmung
nicht aber so kann man doch davon
sprechen dass es eine große
emotionalität in der politik auch gibt
von seiten der wähler und die parteien
stehen dem ihr so ein bisschen ja ein
wenig ratlos gegenüber die csu hat nun
den vorschlag gemacht dass wir viel
stärker volksabstimmung doch ins spiel
bringen sollen
ist das nicht ein geradezu gefährliche
forderungen wenn man die emotionalität
sieht oder würden sie sagen das ist
genau der richtige weg weil das die
demokratie stärkt also zunächst möchte
ich gerne darauf hinweisen dass wir in
deutschland inzwischen eine erstaunliche
bandbreite von möglichkeiten breiter
bürgerbeteiligung haben viel mehr als
das in den gründungsjahren der republik
zunächst einmal absehbar war in allen
landesverfassungen in nahezu allen
kommunalverfassung gibt es mit
unterschiedlichen quoren und
verfahrensregeln die möglichkeit von
bürgerbegehren bürger entscheiden
volksbegehren und volksentscheiden in
den letzten zehn jahren hat es mehrere
tausend solcher initiativen gegeben mehr
als in 50 jahren vorher zusammen
genommen was sowohl belegt dass es ein
gestiegenes partizipations interesse
gibt als auch dass es dafür ein größeres
spektrum an beteiligungsmöglichkeiten
gibt die von manchen für nach wie vor
drehen zu schließende lücke gehaltene
offene frage ist ob man das nicht auch
auf bundesebene ermöglichen sollte da
bin ich sehr zurückhaltend weil ich
glaube dass das auch zu den vielen
klugen entscheidungen gehört die damals
die verfassungsväter und verfassungs
mutter getroffen haben die möglichkeit
einer unmittelbaren beteiligung und da
einer abschließenden entscheidung von
sachverhalten durch wahlberechtigte
bürgerinnen und bürger auf die ebenen zu
reduzieren in denen auch die
überschaubarkeit der sachverhalte
unterstellt werden kann also das heißt
dass die repräsentative demokratie
dadurch unterhöhlt würde würde man es
auf bundesebene begriff unterhöhlen kann
ich mir nicht so richtig anfreunden
mir geht es nicht darum dass ich das
eine mit dem anderen für prinzipien
vereinbar hielte
mir geht es um die frage welcher welcher
legitimation gewinn eigentlich durch
plebiszitäre anstelle von
parlamentarischen entscheidungen
herbeigeführt werden soll
wir haben da ja auch in den gerade auch
in den vergangenen monaten in
deutschland wie im ausland wieder eine
reihe von interessanten erfahrungen
machen können
zunächst fällt mir mal auf dass die
beteiligung bei bürgerbegehren und
bürgerentscheiden unter volksbegehren
und volksentscheiden regelmäßig
niedriger ist als die beteiligung bei
war absolut also dass das jedenfalls die
bevorzugte art der wahrnehmung
politischen einflusses wäre gegenüber
der wahlbeteiligung offenkundig
nachrangig sein ist schon mal empirisch
nicht zu bestätigen
zweitens nehmen wir mal das besonders
spektakuläre beispiel drexhage
großbritannien mit weg auch immer ich in
großbritannien über das thema rede fast
jeder sagt mir wäre diese entscheidung
eine woche früher oder eine woche später
getroffen worden wäre das ergebnis
vermutlich anders gewesen
wie genau anders kann naturgemäß niemand
schlüssig belegen aber dass die
zufälligkeit eines solchen termins mit
den zufälligen stimmungs prägenden
einflüsse wie dabei eine rolle spielen
eine ungleich stärkere rolle spielt als
das bei einer parlamentarischen
entscheidung der fall wäre
darüber gibt es nun keinen vernünftigen
zweifel wir haben dann übrigens auch bei
dieser für die zukunft großbritanniens
übrigens auch für die zukunft europas
besonders wichtigen frage interessante
erfahrungen über die verteilung der wahl
heiligung machen können diejenige
derjenige teil der britischen
bevölkerung der von dieser entscheidung
am nachhaltigsten und längsten betroffen
sein wird nämlich die junge generation
hat von seiner mitwirkungsmöglichkeit am
geringsten gebrauch gemacht wir haben
jetzt die kuriose situation dass die
älteren in großbritannien für die
jüngeren die zu mehr als zwei drittel
für die mitgliedschaft großbritanniens
in europa eintreten
die umgekehrte entscheidung getroffen
haben es fällt mir außerordentlich
schwer darin einen zuwachs an
demokratischer legitimation und schon
gar einen zuwachs an rationalität
politische entscheidung zu erkennen und
was im übrigen mit dieser art der
entscheidungsfindung für das erklärte
ziel der kampagne gewonnen werden
gewonnen sein soll
die souveränität des house of commons
wiederherzustellen
er schließe ich mir nun überhaupt nicht
denn das ist jedenfalls nach der
erklärung der neuen britischen regierung
durch das referendum gebunden obwohl die
rechtsgrundlage für diese
bindungswirkung wiederum völlig
ungeklärt wann das misstrauen würde
vermutlich noch größer wenn man das
votum der bevölkerung kippen würde wir
waren gerade bei europa und wir haben
eingangs der sendung ja darüber
gesprochen dass die verhältnisse äußerst
komplex sind dass politik sich in einem
sehr komplexen umfeld bewegt und sehr
komplexe themen behandeln muss ist eine
neigung gibt zur simplifizierung von
populisten ausgenutzt
ist das auch etwas was in europa und
auch möglicherweise in deutschland den
nationalismus befördert das dass
nationalismus häufig in populistischen
gewand auftritt ist eine nicht ganz neue
erfahrung aber nicht jeder populismus
ist auch nationalistisch deswegen melde
ich mal einen prinzipiellen vorbehalt an
was die gleichsetzung dieser beiden
sachverhalte angeht macht gegenüber
aber was ich ausdrücklich zu meinem
leidwesen bestätigen muss ist dass wir
quer durch europa eine wiederentdeckung
des nationalen haben
was wenn es sich um einen
selbstbewussten patriotismus handelte
eine nicht unsympathische entwicklung
sein müsste es handelt sich aber in
vielen fällen um das gelegentlich
geradezu aggressiv vertretende bedürfnis
wieder den vorrang des nationalen
gegenüber dem europäischen herzustellen
die vermeintliche dominanz europäische
entscheidungen gegenüber nationalen
zuständigkeiten zu korrigieren und das
finde ich außerordentlich betrüblich
zumal ist mir wiederum unaufgeklärt
vorkommt denn für alle großen probleme
vor denen wir stehen in deutschland in
ungarn in frankreich in polen in
großbritannien oder in italien für alle
großen probleme gilt dass wir sie mit
nationaler perspektive nicht überzeugend
lösen können
jetzt sind wir am ende der sendung und
eine frage kann ich mir nicht verkneifen
können wir uns nicht verkneifen
sie haben das zweithöchste amt im staat
sie haben gerade mal wieder ihre
unglaublichen rhetorischen befähigungen
unter beweis gestellt bei ihrer rede am
dritten oktober über die wir schon
gesprochen haben und über deren inhalt
wir gesprochen haben
die einzige aufstiegsmöglichkeit die ja
viele bürgerinnen und bürger auch gerne
sehen wäre ja dass sie auch das
freiwerdende höchste amt im staat
übernehmen
ist das etwas was im bereich des
möglichen ist und was sie auch für sich
sehen könnten
ich bin sehr beeindruckt von den vielen
briefen und gut gemeinten hinweise und
empfehlungen die ich in diesen wochen
erhalte nicht beschäftigt auch sehr die
erkennbare ratlosigkeit vieler sich gar
nicht vorstellen zu können dass man mit
einer aufgabe die man nun über ein
erstaunlich langen zeitraum wahrnehmen
konnte zufrieden ist und sagt das habe
ich gerne gemacht und nun ist es auch
gut aber sind ja auch ein pflichtmensch
nicht nur neigungs mensch und es könnte
ja sein dass sie da sehr gedrängt werden
oder sie werden ja sehr gedrängt und sie
bringen das mit was bei vielen anderen
vermisst wird sind ein brückenbauer sind
jemand der sich eine große
unabhängigkeit erarbeitet hat in einem
über 40 jährigen politischen leben also
prädestiniert für die rolle ja aber
glücklicherweise das gehört auch wieder
zu den gesunden selbstbewusstsein den
blick aufs eigene land sind auch diese
begabungen nicht so selten verteilt das
überhaupt nur einer dafür in frage käme
und da ich selber auch keinen
vollständigen aber inzwischen einen
relativ guten überblick über
persönlichkeit in unserem land habe habe
ich keinen zweifel daran dass es eine
ganze reihe von frauen und männern gibt
die nach meiner festen überzeugung
dieses amt in jeder beziehung ausfüllen
können
und unter den findet sich sicher auch
jemand der es gerne machen möchte und
dazu gehöre ich nicht
dann bedanken wir uns vielmals für das
gespräch und wir bedanken uns bei ihnen
fürs zuschauen